as the truffle mixture sets the powder
coating so have one for the adults and
cocoa powder yes and one with flight
yeah there's a price surprise so wait
for you hands down so look you just go
like that and twist the flake on to the
plate you can coat the truffles and
anything you like finely chopped
pistachios or almonds work really well
with the mint or to give them a bit of
crunch plain brown sugar
once the truffle mixture is set it's
time to roll out the chocolates again -
oh dear right okay I'm going to show you
one first yes her hands really nicely
cold now the secret is in there Wow
that's what you gon manipulate it first
like that and then look roll and then
quickly bang look nothing all my hands
shake off excess and then just on
beautiful now in there let's go come on
Jack
dear hello when you ready be newsy by
time to get one done so try me try and
drop on there rather place on there make
and I think about making them by hand
then all the exact same size yeah
handmade chocolate mint truffles Jack
the secret is a truffle is a one-bite
wonder not a golf ball how do hurry up
cuz of the ganache starts melting we're
in trouble
I thought you said there wasn't give me
any chocolate on your hand cuz you're
slow show me hands no jet let me help
you here
not so not so big round like that like
that yep and then like that in straight
in time for yours in cope about this Sam
look very better myself selves on salsa
by Jack Creek and whilst he's gone let's
turn these into pop a little chocolate
shoulders coming down when the troubles
are coated and the kids are cleaned up
decorate them with sprigs of mint still
looks nice and yes I see that's right
we'd like to try one oh yeah please okay
which one should go for fake or cocoa
snake flake to me testing the gun then
prize the troubles away from the kids
and pop in the fridge ready for
Christmas day another job done